i like a really good life and i have a
very good life
i knew i was a bit different as well
though you know you felt different i did
feel different i was doing
tv shows radio shows i had my own
collection
i had the business oh god how [ __ ] is
that life
and i lost me in that there wasn't times
where it wasn't
fantastic there was but where was i i
didn't stop
to breathe we've really [ __ ] this
planet for you guys
we were blind we're blind consumers
living in life while we
slowly killed the planet and our
well-being so it has to be you guys that
don't know
my mother died when i was very suddenly
of um encephalitis when i was 16
and she was the center of you know the
world and
i had to grow up very quickly and all
that misbehavior
went into sort of responsibility this is
this is
really painful yet somehow i i wasn't
able to express it
[Music]
mary portis you may know her from the
high street you may know her from
business or you may know her from her
books
but the experience i had with her today
is honestly incredible she is hilarious
she is smart she's witty and she is
willing
to be honest at all costs and that
really speaks to one of the central
principles she'll talk about today
which is this idea of the importance of
being true to yourself she's made the
mistake that 99
of people that are listening to this are
going to make are currently making
or are in the process of overcoming
which is living a life that isn't true
to who you actually are
and today she's also going to tell you
about an idea that will be fairly
radical to some people
especially people who are building and
have built big businesses
which is based on her new book rebuild
how to thrive
in the new kindness economy
she has achieved things that most people
in business would never
even dream of she's been a media star
she's been a political figure at times
and through it all through the hardest
of times through grief
through trauma through broken marriages
through public scrutiny in the press
she has emerged as an incredibly
outspoken
honest humble intellectually challenging
and stimulating
humorous inspiration leader entrepreneur
and public figure i laughed i realized
and i was deeply
inspired and you will be too so without
further ado
i'm stephen bartlett and this is the
diary of a ceo i hope nobody's listening
but if you are then please keep this to
yourself
mary um you're a very stand-out person
with a very stand-up personality
and you've managed to achieve some
pretty remarkable things in your life
and
from a place of curiosity that always
makes me wonder what it is that made you
different and
i like to always start with people's
childhoods and their upbringings because
i tend to believe that that's the most
influential part of their life typically
so
is there anything from your um younger
years that you think has been defining
in the person you went on to become
um i well of course i think that that
probably is the case
um i was one of five kids but i was the
fourth out of five
um and uh we were my parents were
irish had come over in their late 50s
from ireland my father was a protestant
my mother was a catholic so you know
from belfast from the north of it um of
ireland so this wasn't
you know they they uh this was the time
when that wasn't looked on too
happily so they came over and chose
watford to live in
[Music]
it could have been dagenham but they
chose watford those were the two options
and
um i'm kind of proud george michael
elton john so we're we're kind of and a
good football team
but i think um i think looking back on
my childhood my my older siblings we
often talk about this we're very very
close it's sort of a two-year one-year
gap between us all
and i was the fourth and i remember
vividly
thinking i'm not the eldest i'm not the
youngest i'm not the first girl and i
didn't feel particularly special
but so i was very um
naughty as a child you know just spent a
lot of time
up to pranks and trying to find my voice
i think really
very loving household um my father was
very
high highly strong hard-working
and my mother was a poetical musical
and was pushed us academically put us
all through the grammar school system
i remember my sister coming home from
school and saying i'm number two
in the class i looked at the register
and my mother said and who was number
one
so i think that gives you a sort of uh
taste of what what life is like but um
we're very close and um but my mother
died when i was very suddenly
of um encephalitis when i was 16.
and she was the center of you know the
world and um
just by the the place where i was in the
family my eldest siblings my elder
brother michael was at university and my
sister was just about to go
and work um go training at uch
and my other brother was hairdressing
and so i ended up looking after being
the one at home
and looking after my younger brother
and i had to grow up very quickly and
all that
misbehavior went into sort of
responsibility
that's what i think happened anyway i
mean you know and i i just took on the
role of the
the i wouldn't say parent because i was
not very good at that at all
but the one who managed stuff at home
and even when my elder siblings then
came back
and to this day you know it's mary's
house that we meet at or
really yeah it's really interesting
because i'm i'm the youngest of four
and i feel like i took on that role
where i feel like i had
because my parents were absent by the
time i was 10. why were they absent
my mom just decided that i think she
decided that she'd raised all of the
kids already you know like yeah it's
almost like they've i've done my
my work as a parent all my brothers and
sisters were older than me
so she would then just sleep at her shop
because she was getting burgled a lot at
her shop
getting lots of like racial attacks on
her shop so she would literally go and
sleep in the back room after after work
wake up work go sleep in the back room
but she had a 10 year old at home
yeah and so i just learned this huge i
had this huge void of independence i
became super naughty
breaking into my school yeah all sorts
of stuff i set far to mine
that was by accident i thought i could
do a little bonfire on
the wooden steps but yeah oh my god the
nuns i was
looked
the passing of your parents
[Music]
at a young age how does that impact you
well mine sort of went from from uh you
know this
terrible traumatic my mother was the
central figure um this sort of fiery
redhead who
just was the backbone and i don't look
back in hindsight i go oh amazing but
she was
i was just about baked just about baked
you know she'd i'd had enough
of love and time from her at 16 i think
my younger brother laurence at 14 that
was terribly difficult so you at 10 i'm
with you i can feel that that that's
that's that's a very lonely place for a
young boy
um but my father remarried
within a year i used to come home from
school and he'd be crying you know and
uh and i was actually then finding
lawrence and i were managing his grief
with these young kids really you know
and he remarried very quickly and um and
then he died
of a heart attack nine months after
getting married
but in doing so left the family home
to the new wife of nine months so we
were all
out on our own really after that and
that i think i look back now
i look back now and i didn't look back
for a long while didn't look back
at all but i look back now and i see
that i was in grief for about four years
i mean i used to walk to school crying
and then just get on the bus and smile
it's grief but i don't you know
somehow i suppressed that and um put it
into
a life that i never dreamt i'd have
that's for sure from that
did you ever get help with that grief
never i remember the headmistress
saying you know if you ever want to come
and talk and the headmistress was a nun
called sister saint james who was you
know this wonderful
actually i really really liked her she
was pretty scared by most standards but
i really liked her
um but that was it i wasn't good against
hitting the headmistresses office and
have a sob
especially with a nun and have to beat
my chest and say about 10 hail marys
so i didn't know i don't think any of us
did this was the
late 70s i didn't remember it's funny
like last night i um i got a little
eight-year-old and he's
into elvis presley for whatever and i
put on some youtube and we were
dancing to elvis presley he was trying
to do the little movements and i said
he said elvis died didn't he mummy in
1977
yes the year my mum died so my mum died
in the july and elvis in the orgs and i
remember everybody grieving elvis
and i was going no and i couldn't get on
this i was like what
and everyone's like elvis has died the
headline so i'm just thinking no my
mom's died
this is this is really painful yet
somehow i
i wasn't able to express her
the grief for those four years how did
how did that impact you
um thereafter and also not processing
that grief
well i think i had a lot of anger yeah i
mean my temper was very quick
i don't have that now i've done a lot of
work on it it's called meditation really
yeah and also being able to come to a
place of acceptance
and and having techniques on but i think
i had a lot of
anger i mean my father would you know
was very quick tempered um but then with
five kids running around screaming the
house i think i would have been
so i think that was there um
and i i don't know i just i think what i
did was i just kept going
blindly i mean i didn't have any any
goal or any vision it wasn't like oh i'm
going to show them
i just kept going and i think what i did
was
ignored the deep sensitivity the deep
me i think i ignored that so i believed
i was this
naughty going fast quick-tempered
individual actually i'm not i'm really
soft
i wasn't that but i didn't know that for
a long long time
was that a was that sort of exterior the
slightly tougher exterior
some form of emotional reaction or
defense from something do you think
because
if that wasn't who you were wondering
where that must have came from
well i think it was a part of my
personality my behavior but i think
i i believe that that was me
and i believed that that was going to be
part of my success you know being
quick-witted
i mean fiery doing things fast
which is you know being a part of my
work but i think i didn't ever discover
the deeper sensitivities and there were
times when i felt vulnerable and there's
times i felt lost and i wanted to be
understood and it was like oh it's mary
and you'd go well no because everybody
judged you on that
it went weirdly even i think the persona
that i had on tv
with the orange bob was that and people
would edit me
to that and i would often think but i
spent so much time behind the scenes
sitting with those
shopkeepers holding their hands or
talking to them but
nobody wants nobody wanted to see that
they wanted to go
and actually yeah it deeply there was
another part of me that wasn't expressed
you talk about this um step mother
i wouldn't even call her that really
what would you call her the woman my
father married i mean i i i
again i i think about that and i'm i'm
talking
with my children on this and um
and when i had to write my memoir you
had to go back on this and and
i just cannot understand anybody
not looking after children who are
grieving for their parents i can't
imagine
you know being with anybody or me
marrying anybody i mean i was married a
second time to a woman
and she took on my children i can't
imagine anybody doing what she did
i just it doesn't fathom in my head
here's a woman
who had a child the same age as my
younger brother who left us
homeless left you homeless well my
father left her
our family home we were 19 and 16.
we had no home we had nowhere to live
and she didn't let you live there oh she
sold it she took it
nine months of being married to my
father after 25 years of marriage in a
family home that he built
are you still resentful about that yeah
no were you at the time
no that's another thing i don't feel
resent
i don't know all we wanted
was for dad to be buried with mum
because you know we were brought up
catholics and
when mum died and she was a deep
catholic
um they we booked the plot so that dad
they have the plot so he can be buried
on the same
ground and she didn't want that so we
had to bring the family priest and go
and see her
and we got that in the end and i no i
didn't ever
ever feel a dot of resentment
do you carry those feelings resentment
regret
yeah bridges i just genuinely don't
regret a thing
my life's been extraordinary i had
extraordinary amounts of pain
extraordinary heights
and it's been colorful and one that i
would never have predicted
when you think about the pain think of
the moments of the greatest pain in your
life what are those moments
um undoubtedly my mother dying that
that um where you wake up and it's
it's like something's on your chest
that was and i remember it was sunny
sunny hot i i didn't like the summer for
years it was july hot
july the late 70s that summer when it
was boiling hot
and i just associated that and i used to
love when it became
automotive cold you could go indoors and
hide it felt like a security
to me and everybody was out playing
tennis and walking and happy
and somewhere and you just this heavy
black
pain deep inside you
um and both separations i've been
you know uh in two big relationships
where i've been married and that
that when you split up a family and i'm
a family person when you have to sit and
go okay how do i do this
how do i do this how do i sit with you
my children and say you know this little
life you've got
this is moving on that was those i
actually remember
you know lying awake three nights on the
road not sleeping
a dot and getting up there must be so
much adrenaline in my body i mean i
don't know
i lost about a stone in weight and i'm
pretty slim i remember putting on my
trousers
dropped below my hips oh my god
that sort of stress and pain but you
have to keep going because you are
responsible
for these children that's what i wanted
to ask you about is having been through
so much
stress and pain which is just this
unavoidable part of the human experience
you can't avoid it right yeah if you try
and avoid it you probably end up with
more
um rumi talks about the bruises the poet
sufi perk roaming the bruises and how we
learn from those bruises
tell me about that well he's just one of
my great
i've discovered him um a 13th century
sufi mystic
and he talks about the bruises that we
hit
and how they repair but that's how we
grow
what have you what have you learned
about how to cope with
unexpected [ __ ] and pain that life
throws at you because you know
you never see it coming i mean a lot of
people have had it over the last 12
months right
last 18 months with the pandemic
couldn't have seen that coming
lots of people's businesses just smashed
to pieces they've lost loved ones
how does one cope with
that kind of like grief whether it's a
professional grief or a
you know um the grief of a lost loved
one or the grief of a lost relationship
is there anything you've learned over
the course of your life where you think
that's probably
the best or only approach well there is
the wonderful line of this too shall
pass and it does
[Music]
for me i have found great
great resolve from some of the great
teachings
and the philosophers who i have read
for a long time now probably about 15 20
years
and and even if we look at the basis of
most religion which is a patriarchy and
has been completely screwed and
bastardised by most men
but actually if you look at the truth at
the heart of it it's much the same thing
that we all have to follow and you have
to just connect
deeply with your inner whatever you call
it whether it's your spirit whether it's
your soul whether it's your
as oprah says my inner frequency you
know when that
gets shelved or you're not aligned
that's when you start to behave
and you follow whatever's happening to
you rather than actually connecting
truly back with your strength your
resource
and so that for me has been and i've
tried to guide my children on that and
actually
found that that has been i wish someone
had done that a little bit more it was
it was shrouded in religion when i was a
kid in the catholic faith which i just
could not connect with at all you know
my mother literally you know going to
confession you used to go into the
church and see these eight-year-old
women beating their chest and saying
dear god you know i've seen anything
what's she done you know this is crazy
this isn't this isn't life what the some
poor old but i'm kneeling down beating
her chest
that's not what the world's about you
know that that's what i've discovered is
if you try and get back to your essence
and
know and try and align and connect with
some deeper strength whether it's
through meditation or whether it's just
pause
and breathe it will come through and it
does
i mean that's not to say we should we
have to go through grief
we have to go through mourning we have
to let that go through our bodies
leaving it in your bodies is the worst
thing you can possibly do and i've done
that over the years and i've
had my back put out i've been laid low
because it's in there
so i've i've learned to do that i had
you know first when covered hit it was
shocking for me i mean all my clients in
my business which has been my backbone
for 21 years
just closed down and and nobody said are
you guys okay
they just stopped work i had 55 people
well what the actual [ __ ] is happening
here
and i'm talking to my kids about being
connected to your source and i'm like
jesus wept i've got to pay for all this
and i don't know where i'm going to do
this and i'm just looking down the
barrel at 60 and i suddenly went into
that complete
fear i was like you need to pull this
back i was
actually pretty i felt i was a little
bit ashamed that i wasn't better
if i'm honest i was such a shock
such a shock and i've written about it
in the first chapter of my book because
i want it was so shocking and it was
like well they were falling down like
dominance
that the the clients and we were like
what we thought as a business was just
going
[Music]
um and it just slowly but surely i kept
on connecting back to that
sense of me that deep truth that the
world would look after you
there was a great interview i heard and
i can't remember who it was
and i can't remember i'd like to think
but i remember he was a he was a
a philosopher and he and he said we're
talking about money
and he said think of a time when you've
never had enough
can't think of a time when i've never
had enough money i've had very little
money
but i've lived and i remember just
holding on to that
when it when is the world never ever
truly looked after you
and if you can realign back into that
sense of
connecting and not go for the short term
whether it's you know following a route
that you're you're trying to short term
fix it through stress or through that
anxiety
and you connect back to that true source
it always works
you said during the pandemic you you
felt
it almost was as if you were saying you
felt shame that you weren't
good enough i wanted to get
more detail on what you mean by that no
what i meant was that i i
the work that i'd done on myself on
knowing
that you know this too shall pass
connect back you will be all right the
world will look after you
i i didn't well it took about a month
and then i was like okay and i had
all the kids under one that was
homeschooling happening
i was on you know phone every single
morning with the ceo of my business we
were on
facetime it was you know we were on zoom
calls hideous it was like
all the time it was this world that
you'd been thrown into
where i thought all right you know
approaching 60 ease up now port us
you know you don't need to be doing as
much everything just fell apart
bam like that like that
oh my god what has happened here
so i was a bit disappointed that i
wasn't more
you know arm baby really okay
i was like sort of done a lot of work on
myself but i got it back i got it back
she says talk to me about so i want the
detail as to because i i read that
you'd said you you felt like you were
spiraling
out of control a little bit when the
pandemic first struck and i think a lot
of people can relate to that
that sense of um panic total uncertainty
and i mean we had all of our like high
street clients
completely just cancel all work not even
because they were
they'd gone bankrupt but because they
just didn't have certainty themselves so
yeah
they just stopped it was either like
totally stopped or paused or wait we
don't know what's happening here right
so if i and you you have in your agency
you have
pretty much all high street players
right so i can't imagine
and so i want to know when you say you
were spiraling what does that mean
uh well for example one of my clients
was a big piece of business that would
do the other side of the world i won't
mention
it was a million and a half pounds bam
clothes done
stop that stopped you like what what i
meant by that was i
i've never in 21 years ever had anything
where i thought
financially i've made myself so
financially secure
over those years i've never had anything
that thought that might go
i've never i've never wanted huge
amounts i like a really good life
and i have a very good life but i've
never wanted
you know the big amounts i've always
thought you know this is this is really
good and i so i've never i've always
shared the pie as it were you know i
like a big slice of the cake but i also
i like sharing it out so i was never
i've gone ahead i've got
never that i like a lovely life and
and so suddenly this was like that might
not be the case
and you are the young lad that you've
got to put through school
you might be working till you're 70
whatever
to get this back up but i was like i
don't want to do that
you know so it was going against my my
flow and my energy as well you know
that i wanted to go off and do other
things i was ready to go and do the
the things that one should be doing at
60 plus when you've had a
very big career and doing stuff that and
i suddenly go oh god i've got to get
this back on
and so i just didn't like the way that
that frightened me
it did frighten me you know there were
sleepless nights
but then suddenly this place of
acceptance came and you realize
there was magical times where i thought
i am in lockdown with all three of my
kids
you know one of which had left home
one who's doing a masters and one who
was eight
this isn't going to happen again you
know and there were times where they
were just out in the grass playing
around with us together
and that's that's the magic you know
that's the magic for that little man
there with his big
brother and sister there were times we
just would sit up on um
a place near us in swift's hill and just
look at flowers and draw flowers and i
thought
this isn't going to come again like this
and so i was able to sort of
slowly but surely build back
and things got better and there's a huge
debate now about
what the new normal will look like
especially as it relates to working
and remote working and i wanted to get
your stance on
this whole remote working debate i'll
give you my opinion first because my
opinion tends to be quite controversial
i tend to think people have
overestimated the um
remote working thing and i say this
because i believe that the office is one
of the last sort of institutions of like
community and human connection
dating's gone socializing facebook
social media
dating we now have all these dating apps
and it's felt like in my life especially
as like a 25
26 year old whatever that going to the
office was actually one of the places i
actually got to meet people
in my life and and connect and form
communities and go to a football team as
an adult
and if that all moves to zoom now like
every other part of my life is dictated
by
a glass illuminated screen i worry
and we have had people sat in the chair
from
mental health psychologists and all
sorts and the the consistent theme
for them has been if you can give
someone community and connection in
their life
then they um then they do better they
are healthier and i felt like the office
especially i know you've got an amazing
office i've read about it i've
read about the atmosphere there and and
how impressive that is and we also
went to great lengths when i was reading
about your office it felt a lot like
mine
it's not hierarchical you wouldn't know
who was in charge people are themselves
it's very flexible and open we don't
have these rigid archaic systems in
place
and so it was a really enjoyable place
to be and i would hate
for that places like that to be um
to disappear i think the old office has
to change and die
and be reinvented but i wanted to get
your take on that
well i think you said it i think you
know i think i think there's a lot of
businesses jumping on the bandwagon
thinking how can we you know save money
on rent
yes and not looking at the mental health
well-being i've seen this
i think my officers we opened them up as
soon as we could
we have two days where we say we want
everybody in
because we believe that is everything
you've talked about
and i know even when i go in and i will
see them all
and we will have a laugh and we'll talk
about stuff that's
not even in the work world but those
nuggets those little
messages those little nuances that
happen
are what makes us human it's ridiculous
to think we do i heard google aren't
opening those up for another year and
you think
what the actuals stop this have they
actually
asked their people i have a young
daughter who's been working at home
consistently since she went out to the
world of work
and it is not good for her mental
well-being
and i have watched my children get up at
8 00 a.m
and go straight on zoom that was where's
where's the travel time
where you listen to a podcast or you
listen to a piece of music
or you read something or you bump into
someone on the street and say morning
do you fancy your coffee yeah where's
that gone out of our lives we take this
away
and we take what it is to be human if
you
when i did my high street report i
talked about exactly what you're talking
about
we lose this we lose
what jane jacobs who wrote the death of
the american city
back in the 60s well before i talked
about this she talked about those little
things where you bump into someone on
the street and you say morning are you
getting a newspaper and you say can you
daughter babysit tonight
she said these little things are trivial
but the sum isn't trivial at
all it is a social infrastructure a web
of security that makes us human
the office is the same the office is the
same now i started in my office was
saying you've got a baby you can bring
it in
bring dogs in this was like
10 years ago what you know we need to
ease up and realize
that we need more of this in our lives
i've had to sublet parts of my office
because we had too much space
but we bloody went out and sublet and
fought because we wanted to keep it
because i knew
that this was deeply important
especially to your generation
and you know i know there's people and
and my kids have seen it they
they said that the sort of 40 pluses
yeah it's nice having some time i
understand that
you can pick up the kid you of course
but let's get that balance
let's get that balance and you're right
the more we close down
the more we squeeze our little souls
because those small trivial things are
what make
up our lives i know that so i
would be so pro it i i really think this
needs to be the things
that are part of our society which are
deeply important that do need bloody
government intervention i know tories
don't want to intervene and it's a free
market and all that crap
transports one our high streets are one
our national health service is another
and the way we
work and connect i think is another so i
would be putting this on the agenda i
heard on one of those
what is it called question times which i
keep getting asked to go and i think oh
dear god
um and i was listening to there nobody
was all these sort of aging politicians
who
weren't running businesses who didn't
see the impact
of not of of getting together it's it's
vital please please anyone listening and
if you're listening and you're a
millennial or a gen z
and you don't think you've got any power
pull together get your pals and put
pressure at the top
an awesome open back up
i think that clip will go viral on
linkedin so that's that's great i think
you can reach a lot of people with that
one
my linkedin's very highly engaged so i
think that'll bang um but no i
you know i think that i'm more at ease
because i think in the professional
world it's going to become a battle
of um employees choosing
where they want to spend their time and
where they want to work and so my
objective here isn't to
so what i what i tend what i feel like i
saw was
these kind of fragile dare i call them
leaders in business
doing all this kind of virtue signaling
on on social media and online going
oh we're going to let our employees
decide and if they want to work and i
i've said
publicly like you as a leader you have
to have a backbone and your company
culture should be reverse engineered
from the mission
so you know if you're if you're i don't
know building cars then you need your
people at the factory but also
work should be it should offer more than
just pay
and if it is to offer more than pay
something meaningful it would be
community connection
and these things so my stance as an
employer is i'm going to create the
environment which offers you more
community than you're going to get
anywhere else
good pay more free more flexibility
around things that matter in your life
kids etc and i think i'll be able to
hire all your staff
that you have working from a zoom screen
at home and i think eventually you'll
figure that out and you'll go back
but yeah and that's my [ __ ] yeah
that's what i think i think it's a
competition of like the anatomy i'm with
you
you know it's it's look you as i say
you're young
i remember when i wrote work like a
woman i was like looking at this and
thinking who
who created the code who wrote this [ __ ]
how do we want to work i want people in
my business that have a voice that feel
i will sit with a 23 year old and i know
we'll sit and have a great conversation
as much as
the 45 year old is running the business
i we've actually put that with these two
days
when the chief execs in we want everyone
in
because this is the time when we learn
this is the time we laugh and we
really do laugh i mean i'm the biggest
joker the biggest kid in the office of
mine
and my daughter's been coming in so she
can get some just some interaction she
works in food policy because something
completely different
and she goes mom you're the biggest kid
i said i know i need people around me i
need it and i
love to laugh and it's just fantastic
when you're in an office and you hear
that
and it's not difficult this stuff you
know it's all about
when you feel as confident as you do
you're able to give up that control yeah
that's what you're giving up and saying
you know what i know who i am
and i want you who works with me to know
who you are
and so let's give up that control that
doesn't mean that i'm going to have any
lazy bath
coming in and you know sauntering in
whenever they want and taking no
they know i talk about the kindness
economy the kindness economy is doing
what's humanely right
it's not taking the piss so you have
very you know
strong ethos and ethics and guidelines
of what you believe
your business is and where you want to
go but let everybody be themselves
within that
and part of that is connection i mean
it's fine for me sitting in my north
london
you know home working or i'm in the
cotswolds what about the ones who i've
seen them on zoom
in their bedroom sharing a flat you're
waking
in there and you're doing zoom and if
any
owner of a business or organization
isn't understanding that
shame on you and think about it they're
then probably
picking up a phone to do their dating
then when they're hungry
they they pick up the phone and open
ubereats and deliver and order their
food
and it's conceivable that this
generation and i actually write about it
my book i show how we're getting more
and more stagnant as the years go on
because we're optimizing for
productivity and financial gain as
opposed to human connection we're
actually optimizing we're doing
everything in our power
to sacrifice human connection and
socializing and even things like
exercise and movement
for increased productivity and um
i think it's time to you know i do i
think the government would be effective
in intervening
i mean oh i've given up yeah i was going
to say i don't know what they ain't
going to come from them
they had some like loneliness i think
theresa may appointed the first ever
loneliness tsar for the uk
who was that jesus i don't know but i
have been knocking on your door there
dystopian like
image of this like these like tanneries
in the streets being like [ __ ] talk
to each other like
do you know what i mean like i just feel
like
i think um i think it's going to come
that's why in my book i think it's going
to come from business and i think it's
going to come from people like us
changing that 100 percent agree i think
it's 100
politics i think once we get past this
little woke virtue signaling thing which
leaders are doing now where they're like
we'll just let our employees
do whatever they want and they can just
be all out whatever i think then you'll
have the second wave of that which is
um which is reality um you need to talk
about it on your show you need to talk
about this when you're doing business
you need to get this out there
you need to be a voice for that because
you know it's
um it's only by sharing our voices and
having an opinion doesn't matter who
knocks us so who comes back that you go
no
this feels right this feels right this
is deeply important
deeply important to the next generation
you know we've
really [ __ ] this planet for you guys
you know my generation i've
you know we the generation before me the
the um
the baby boomers they know that so we
have to
we have to hold on to something deeply
precious here and there is a movement
and understanding is
greater and deeper we were blind we were
blind consumers we thought that having
it all
was having more stuff and living a life
while we slowly killed the planet
and our well-being so it has to be you
guys that go no
if we get one thing out of this that's
going to be there that we're going to
change
all those ridiculous ideas that my
generation and the baby boomers bought
into
quick one i'm trying to get in good
shape for summer as i imagine a lot of
people are
and just in time for summer you'll have
released what i consider to be one of
the most important best products they've
ever released
i'm gonna have to say second to the rtd
ready to drink yours which basically
saved my life on a daily basis
it's this protein they've released 100
calorie 20 gram protein that has 26
of your vitamins and minerals in
incredibly complete and healthy for you
and the salted caramel protein is my
favorite flavor it tastes unbelievable
and i've mixed it with water
usually when you have protein powder
mixed with water it tastes awful it
tastes like ass
but this is genuinely delicious so if
you're going to start your journey with
fuel or if you're a current customer and
you've not tried the protein yet
i highly recommend specifically if you
like salted caramel like me
you give this a while back to the
podcast
you say they're having it all and having
more stuff we thought that was it which
leads me
into something else i wanted to talk to
you about i read you'd said um
that you're in the public eye you're
making more money than ever and it was
extraordinarily exciting but at
the age of 48 you found yourself crying
almost every day
i was probably physically exhausted um
i just didn't get that joy you know i
just was on this
i was doing tv shows radio shows
i had my own collection i had the
business
i had two kids it was it was crazy
and and i was the nature i was the scent
it wasn't like
you know i had some husband who was
raising
me it was me you know and i thought yeah
but i and the more that comes you'll
know this the more it comes the more it
comes the more it comes
comes keep coming keep coming keep
coming you got to do this gotta do that
and there were parts of it that was just
you know incredible i looked back at it
what
some great years but i was exhausted
and you're not allowed to say that
actually i was thinking about that at
that time there would be those
you know women on the front of the
sunday times magazine like that we can't
show our pose but it'll be like that
you can have it all they got eight kids
and they would get up and they would be
doing you know yoga at 6 00 a.m and then
having a global call with china or
whatever then you know they'd be
bringing dropping the kids off at school
while chatting to god those whoever
sorting out
the day and you just thought oh god how
[ __ ] is that life
where are you where are you and i lost
me
in that it there wasn't times where it
wasn't
fantastic there was but where was i
i didn't stop to breathe i didn't stop
to truly connect
truly connect with me and i remember i
went away
um to some very expensive spa place
where it was all
on shanty and downward dogs and eating
stuff and everyone's all this
you know you go where rich people are
because you got money and you go and you
discover you
and um and i remember sitting in this
yoga session and i just was crying and i
was like
please stop please don't marry please
stop and there's all these sort of
women in their lululemon and i was going
just crying
and i thought and i went in to um
there was this wonderful indian guru
i used to sit in this little room which
you could go and meet and chat with and
i remember going in to see him
and he didn't say a word and i just was
crying i didn't want to speak with him
but i wanted to go to the bookshelf that
was behind him
because i knew there were some books
there and i picked up
eckhart tolle's new earth
and i just took it and as i left he went
that's the right one
and i went back to my room and i read it
and i read it on the beach days and i
was like oh my god i've got the world
wrong i've just completely got this
wrong
and that was a start of my journey
it took many years i'm still you know
getting still
partly hybridizing that life i'm never
going to sit in an ashram but
i i discovered how to connect back
truly with me and stop loading this
stuff in your life mary
and and saying no two questions there
which is
regarding this book this eckhart tolle
book that you you talk about
um a new earth what was it what was the
the key lessons that
imparted on you about life and how
you're living
i'm i was living totally outwardly to my
ego and my persona
marry portis mary with bob mary the
business woman
marry the mother i was not connecting
truly with
who my spirit my soul
so everything was done to feed that
and you believe that that is you you
believe that that is your personality
you believe
all of that you talk about you thought
you'd become a bit of a caricature
oh for sure but i also milked that that
was very profitable
but you know i knew it was brand mary
the red bob the rings you know i've
always loved fashion awards lots but it
was very much you know
a signature so and um
yeah of course i mean i i advise
businesses globally on brands i was i
suppose a brand why itself
and i i just didn't want to be that
anymore philosophy is very clear on this
idea of like abandoning your true self
and the consequences of your ego you're
out
yeah yeah and it seems like such a
clearly
losing game and i think people listening
to this are probably have to be well you
are some stage in the process you've
either
um you're probably you're either at the
start and you've not yet tried to
abandon yourself
because you think that you know because
the outside world has convinced you and
incentivized you to do so
especially social media that'll have you
trying to abandon yourself and become
the kardashians whatever whatever or you
are in the process of
um abandoning yourself or trying to and
you're feeling
the sense of despair and probably lack
of orientation that comes with that or
you've come out the other end which it
kind of sounds like you've
you've got to where you've realized that
you try to abandon yourself and the only
true answer is to
to be yourself because everything else
is despair you either succeed in
abandoning yourself as this one
i think it's called stoddard this
swedish philosophy used to say
if you succeed in abandoning yourself
then you end up in despair
if you fail in abandoning yourself then
you end up in despair so the only
true true path to joy is to
accept who you are yes i think you know
the thing is it's you know it's knowing
what the truth is it doesn't mean that
we're not going to have on
this we are truly connecting on a truth
here i don't think we're
you know performing but part of it is
performative because we are doing
a job that's going to be this podcast
but it's being on the path some people
never even know that past there
you know most people don't and that
you know it i remember when i first
discovered it and people like don't
you know don't talk about that because
you might sound a bit odd on you know
spirituality or blood don't talk about
that and you're like
and i didn't for a long while you know i
i
even was chatting to a great producer at
the bbc saying why isn't there a show on
something like this
on the bbc like no don't mention
spirituality in the bbc at the moment
you're like what this this needs to get
out there
and it's not hokey pokey stuff this is
our truth
and i think what i've tried to do is to
allow
the people who work with me
express that and know about it and we
share it we share it in the business
and it just opens this whole thing up
and there are times when you have to be
as i say performative and be
i'm mary portas you know going out i'm
working i'm writing a piece or i'm doing
a course but i'm rooted in who i am
deeply and i think it isn't whether
whatever we call it whether it's
spirituality whether it's our soul
whether it's our spirit whether it's our
truth whether it's our vibration whether
it's our
you know whatever our vortex
or our frequency is oprah says whatever
getting back to that you know i remember
and i was listening to
the um lovely irish uh
irish poet and i'll think of this
surname and i'll think about it and
they'll all come to me after i've done
this but anyway i remember him
talking about when he used to give the
last rights he's been ireland and he'd
go
to give the last rights to whoever was
dying and he'd go in
and he'd see these little pinched faces
that had lived a life that wasn't in
line with their true
self because they couldn't they had no
choice and
he just said it used to make him feel so
so
sad and then he would give them the last
rights and he would literally see the
pain on their faces their
skin just un un stress
and un wrinkled because they were able
just to be
and that is the greatest gift i think we
can give to anything and and to our kids
you know i mean i put them through a
great
academic system because i could but i
always said
you choose i remember my daughter coming
to me when she just finished oxford she
got into oxford and she was like
um i was deeply proud
and she finished a degree and she said
mom i know
everyone's going to expect me to go in
and make a lot of money i don't want to
do that
i said why do you explain that to me
like you know i'm really going to judge
you on that
and um she wanted to do something that
just connected not with which
but with where her truth was and that's
the only thing i think we need to try
and find in life now your truth probably
was that you know
you wanted to get to that place where
you were able to say
i did this because that's the truth that
was important to you because everyone
else is saying you can't do something
you're not sitting in this system i was
much the same
much the same yeah i met some old school
friends they were like
whoa you know my life because i was just
always the one in trouble or
i remember getting 17 percent in physics
and thinking i don't give a [ __ ]
i don't give a [ __ ] oh my god i was like
17 i never felt embarrassed i was just
like
i knew i was a bit different as well
though you know you felt different
i felt different but i wanted to be like
the middle class girls
that were living in charlie wood and i
came from the working class
so it was the kids from watford that got
into
the grammar school that that were the
sort of that parents didn't have the
money we used to get the bus out and
then the middle class from charlie wood
and all those areas just
their parents used to drop their cars
and then they'd get to the sixth floor
they drive in themselves i was like oh
my god i want to be this
and then i went nah nah
i don't want to be that life oh my life
i want my life
brony ware talks about the same thing
she interviewed people on their
palliative patients i think it's called
on there who does this
brony ware she was a an australian
palliative nurse i don't know if that's
the right word
and she interviewed people on their
death bed and asked them one question
which was what's your biggest regret
as they were dying wow the number and
she released the blog and it the number
one regret of the dying
as she writes in her blog was quote not
living a life true to myself
oh man i remember watching the film of
alan turing and it just actually
heartbreaking and here was a gay man who
could not
live his life and i just thought that
has got to be i think that sort of
the 50s and 60s was worse than any time
you know that american dream of the
housewife and being the the
two kids and living the american dream
and
actually you had to suppress your
sexuality
your frequency your truth your love
your ability to soar isn't that just
the worst torture torture
torture daily hourly yeah
yeah subconscious torture almost yeah
and it's still going on in hollywood
yeah
you you married a man i did marry a man
then a woman then a married woman
and i'm with a woman now well i never
it's interesting i i don't
i don't know whether female sexuality is
particularly different
from male sexuality but i'm
i've been in love with two men in my
life and i've been in love with two
women
i've never sort of i never was a child
oh my god i'm a lesbian
i fancy linda evangelista i've got to do
something about it
i know i had relationships with women i
had relationships with men and
it just didn't ever bother me um but
once i
had fallen in love with the woman i
remember you know saying to my
sister she was like but you're not a
lesbian i said well i don't know what i
am do i have to put a label to it
and the interesting thing is
when i did and you know and married mal
that
all the prides and the you know they'll
grab hold of you and put lesbian
oh okay well i've got to do this for the
sake of all of you and be a voice
which i wanted to be but you kind of
also go now you're also labeling me yeah
it was a really but i also don't want to
let you down stone war
and i will do the opening speech at
pride because i know you need women and
i've just had another one that came
through on you know lgbt
virgin radio mary would you go into
right
i don't want to be also categorized in
that way because i'm not a former prison
as well though isn't it well it is
but i also don't want to not be a voice
because i think it's important for
you know when when i did uh meet mel
there wasn't there was
no women in the public eye besides sandy
toxic
who were in same-sex relationships and i
remember this
my children having to you know when they
went to school there was no books on it
i mean i'm talking what are we milo's
now 26 so i'm talking you know he was
nine
there wasn't so i thought i had to do
that and i did it and i don't mind doing
it
but you know there is a fluidity to it
labels good and bad yeah those kind of
labels those like
socially categorizing labels where they
put you in the label
because they maybe want to understand
you but because they want you to rep
like lead the charge of a movement i get
that obviously young black
yeah yeah you know guys there's not
actually many many of us up here in the
young
yes male represent category
and i'm only actually half black i'm as
black as i am white because my dad's
like my mum's black and i'm like i will
represent the black people
yeah stand behind me and then you feel
okay yeah you say yeah as you say
yeah you know there's probably a net
positive impact of me doing that for
society
so i'll take on that uh responsibility
but then i go back to well i know who i
am so write what you're saying
write what you like and say what you
like because
i know intuition hmm topic i've heard
you talk about a lot
you'd said previously that the biggest
mistakes in your life had come from not
listening to your intuition
[Music]
what comes to mind when i say that which
mistakes i think you know i i think i'll
know when i'm
needed to have got out of you know
relationships and
it kept telling me something and kept
telling me and you're like oh no
no i've suppressed that i've suppressed
it in times where i've you know thought
in business i don't particularly like
this person
and yet they pay me a lot i've
suppressed that
and it always ends up always you know
you feel it you feel it and ideas
sometimes you know ah they just come
if you're really really feeling free
and in tune they just come and they're
they're wonderful it's been my
it's been my i'm sure it's yours but
it's been my
you know ability to sort of feel
something deeply know that that's right
and you can get people that can analyze
put data behind it logic and i've
listened to them in the past and i've
let things go ah
not regret but oh that
you know even you know now
i i've always bought i've always wanted
to do and it's just trying to get an
idea you know a totally
sustainable secondhand recycled
vintage take a whole space like a
massive mail that's closed down and
create tomorrow's
where you everything is about you know
recycled upcycled vintage remote
and i've got to get on and do that but
it's too big
but i just know it will you know and so
i have to follow the instinct on on
doing that
but i think just just sometimes you just
it's the small things as well it's just
the small things where you feel
it's come from there and you push it
down because you put too much logic and
reason behind it
and i think in business we need to let
that open up so much more
certainly in my area of business i
reckon we ended up with such
so many crap businesses because logic
data and systems overtook
instinct creativity and innovation and
we need to bring that back
and interestingly you talking about high
streets what has come back is
people understanding the importance of
connection and community
through high streets and we will see
that coming back um
and i you know i had the labour party
get in touch with me and saying they
wanted to re
you know look at what we were doing on
the high street report 10 years ago
because when i did it 10 years ago
they didn't understand that it was all
about bottom line
all about bottom line what's your view
on
the younger younger generation coming up
you know there's a lot of i think we
talked off
off microphone about um some of the
themes coming out of
you know this this uh instagram
generation like
you know it's like really binary cliches
like find your passion
there's this idea that like um working
hard is now
toxic um and just generally what you
what
what's your if you were to impart advice
or you were to give a perspective on
this kind of like instagram generation
who and their perspective of the working
world um
what advice would you have for them
i think you know the there's the good
and the bad and the ugly isn't there i
mean i think
it's i think it's a really tough world
to be in
that you are always on that's a very
tough place to be
um and i purposely you know don't do as
much even though i should be you know
because i just say i only want to do
something when i really have something
to say
and i know it drives some of my agents
around the bend you know it's in social
media
yeah and i think it's deeply difficult i
think we've got
two strands coming through i think we
it's used as an incredible place for
voice and change to happen and i think
the gen z's
are going to be probably the best
generation that we've seen in
a very very very long time and the more
i read about the more my i have a social
anthropology unit
in my agency the more we research this
the more i utterly love them and i'm
more i want them to make this world
better
and i think they will and you young
millennials absolutely i think
and i think there's a lot that comes out
of it that's fantastic
the other part of it is oh boy i would
love
to change what are now used as icons and
role models especially around beauty
fashion
and young women it is just too much to
live up to
and i i find it that i find
just terribly stressful for individuals
and the way that they've been sold how
they need to look how they need to
behave how their body needs to be what
their beauty regime should be
it's it's ridiculously tough and i you
know i
i live in a society where i'm seeing a
young generation that are pushing
against that but there's an
awful lot of young women particularly
and men out there
who how they are looked and how they're
perceived and what their life is like
and and 40 pluses i look at some people
on facebook and i think
really you're still doing this [ __ ] you
need to go out there and
show what new shoes you've bought or
what you had for brunch and where you at
really really isn't it a bit of a
pyramid scheme and not a pyramid maybe
like a
network marketing scheme in some
respects or
some kind of like network effects
because what's happening is you let's
say you've got
i don't know the kardashians at the top
then you've got people below them
looking up at the kardashians and
thinking [ __ ]
you know what i need to get fake bum and
i need to change this and i need to
change this and i need to post
when i'm wearing my chanel bikini on the
side of that boat so they'd
follow suit which then cascades
downwards and everyone's just trying to
this is what i'm talking about the
pressure i'd love the kardashians to
turn around and say let's not buy any
more stuff and let's recycle wouldn't it
be brilliant
imagine what that would do for
consumerism that's probably the
most impact they could have in the world
is if they just cut out the fakery and
yeah lived more ethically but they just
they're pinned back by
the financial incentive but i you know
when i was doing my research in my book
and looking at the spend
on the pressure on young people
who follow the kardashians to get the
new this the new that
it's insane it's insane
because i used to look back and think
well you know my mother couldn't afford
stuff
so we just we just put up with it but we
weren't sold the marketing dream
we weren't sold this [ __ ] and this has
gone
so deeply into society so deeply that we
do need people like you that go this is
just
crap standing up and saying this is crap
and anyone comes on dragon's den trying
to sell that crap
it's almost like the way i see it is um
like social media in this
that the world the kardashians it's like
they're holding a bit of your
self-esteem hostage
and the ransom of the apparent ransom is
you've got to go get that bag too
or whatever and then when you pay the
ransom you get the bag
you don't get your self-esteem back and
it just increases the ransom just
increases now they're like now you've
got to get an even better bag
and it's just endless like that's
exactly what i wrote about i was part of
that
when i was creative director at harvey
knicks i was i sold this stuff to people
thank you yeah
bloody brilliant look i'm gonna make
this sexy and
and uh and it was it's not dissimilar
now it's just got faster and faster and
faster and faster and faster
and it is totally all based on i'm not
good enough
i'm not good enough we have to convince
them that there's something they don't
have but need
we really need this revolution there is
part that are doing
it but there's a whole part of society
that are still buying into this
this lack of self-esteem and we as
marketers have been selling that
for years i've definitely been selling
that yeah so
at my previous mayor business
quick one as you guys might know if
you've been paying close attention
i'm in the process of starting a brand
new business and when you're starting a
business there are a million things to
do from branding to websites to all
sorts right
logos videos promotions all of this
stuff and so it's incredibly hard to do
all of these things when you were a
one-man
or woman band and that is where
fiverr.com comes in and solves a huge
problem for me
if you've never used the website before
it is the best place to find
freelance support across multiple
services in the most cost-effective
and reviewed and rated way and i use it
in every sort of facet of my
professional life including
for this podcast sometimes and including
in my businesses and as i start my new
business
which i'm going to tell you about soon
i've started to rely on it once again so
go to fiverr.com
ceo and check out how amazing fiverr.com
is
you said you know it was something that
i i thought maybe i was the only person
in the world that also felt which was
before we started recording you said
that you don't get excited about things
yeah i mean i have great things in my
diary or someone said oh aren't you
excited you're doing that tomorrow and i
just think no i just don't get excited
and
you said you don't either i don't know
well i so i didn't actually say anything
but then
my camera guy here jack that's worked
with me for some time says steve always
says that
and it's because there's people who will
say to me oh my god you're doing this
next week or you're going on holiday or
going to this place or you're speaking
in dubai
are you excited and no yeah when they
hit me with the question i go
no no as if you're trying to work that
through because i've never sat with
anyone and worked that through or talked
that through and
and but it doesn't stop me really
enjoying like
experiences the experiences and there
and now i don't put it up there maybe
that's the thing
for me i thought and i might be wrong
but maybe we're going to work it through
now i thought
my lack of excitement was a defense
mechanism because i also need to defend
against going down
when bad things happen so i think over
time i've just
developed this character trait where i'm
just here in the moment focused on what
i have to do right now and i'm trying to
be
stable and calm so i don't swing upwards
with great news i don't swing
downwards too heavily with bad news and
that also means i don't swing too far
into the future
or swing too far into the past that's a
really good maybe
that's it because my friends get excited
about small things and big things
well i've got dinner table at brat and
you're like
great but it doesn't it doesn't excite
me yeah i don't know that maybe that is
maybe that is a subliminal thing that
we've both done i
i hadn't thought about that but i felt i
even had it like
my my partner said to me oh you've got
that aren't you excited
and i said no and i actually have to
tell you i don't get excited
but my girls going into therapy yeah you
have to sit you down and tell you i
don't get it that doesn't mean i don't
feel joy yes
that doesn't mean i don't feel complete
but i don't get excited or maybe
someone's going to listen to this some
really
incredible psychoanalyst and they're
going to go we'll go and we'll work this
out and tell you why
it is really interesting because you as
i think it's so important for you
for you to say what you've said there
which is you still enjoy yourself when
you're there and doing these things
but it's like future anticipation
and i think that must come from living
having lived a very
intense life where the most important
thing in your world is
being in the present right now and
fixing the thing right in front of you
yes
and you've probably not had a ton of
time to sit but then also also i have to
say the privilege of having
had so many great experiences yes
you know so there's not really a
restaurant you've not been to that's
been a mate you know like you've been to
amazing restaurants you've been to
amazing places you've done
achieved amazing things so you're bro
you're sort of like threshold of what
might
it doesn't seem that anything excites me
you know i remember
now you've said something and i remember
just i i think it's being what you talk
about totally connected i remember
a true surge of joy coming through my
body
[Music]
when i was walking through a supermarket
this is nothing to do with the
supermarket
but i had my baby daughter in front of
me
and i had my husband with me with my
little son and i was
totally in a place of joy in a
supermarket
but there was something about this
place of these two beautiful kids i had
love it's just and i remember
this search coming and i'm like i feel
really happy
and i've had other times like that and
they've not been
sitting in can at a restaurant they've
been
really fundamental
simple simple simple places
where i felt that surge of joy okay
where you where you feel you're an elect
i can feel it now right the way you can
put it and you can feel your energy
going through your body which is
beautiful
and i would rather have that than this
excitement
if i told you that later today you were
going to
walk down the street and feel that same
surge of joy that you got from the
supermarket would you be excited
no if i told you now that when you walk
out this this door you're gonna as you
walk out down the street
i promise you you're gonna feel that
surge of joy would you be excited to
no but i feel that warmth and that
energy going through my body that thinks
yes i want to be in that place
but it's not excitement and because what
i was trying to figure out there
is if excitement to us i was trying to
figure out if we
the reason why we don't get excited is
because we've realized that true joy
doesn't come from the restaurant or from
the
holiday or from the the going and doing
the tv thing whatever
it's actually really the joy comes from
something that's actually very hard to
predict it's like those
really meaningful moments and so when
someone says are you excited to go to do
that experience on tv you think well
that's not joy
and in fact joy will come in those
really random moments random yeah
i sat in the garden with my sister last
week and i my sister and i love my
sister
she's just one of the great people i
know
she was always quieter as a kid and she
always let me be like she was three
years older but she
was always like you know when she was 18
and i was 15 she'd take me out to the
clubs like no one's done it you know
like she was like come on
and i just sat with her it was just a
moment we were just sitting together we
weren't speaking
and it was just that moment where that
connected you can see it in your face
when you when you describe these moments
yeah your face lights up
yeah that that's joy that's what that's
why
when you talk about the office and we
talk about the high street
it's the trivial what we think are
trivial that's what
makes the world that's what makes life
that's what fuels us
laughter in the hallways and those
little jokes and catching up on what
happened on the weekend and stuff
totally or like me trying to wash the
dog in the garden the other way and
i my partner nearly was waiting for
laughing because i couldn't get the dog
i said bam over here
the hose was going everywhere and it was
just that moment of madness
and joy that the little dog running
around the garden it was just those
things
but also maybe we don't resonate i was
just thinking then with the word
excitement because think about what that
word means when i think of the word
excitement i think
that's not a that's not a state that i
live my life in never so
when someone said are you excited i
think well am i oh
no no never so maybe there's a better
question which is
are you looking forward to the
experience or are you um
i don't know maybe there's a better
question but i don't do that either yeah
looking forward isn't because you're not
looking forward to it
you know are you happy you're doing it i
don't know
your mission now in life seems to be
focused a lot on them as you say like
making businesses kinder
and it seems to be much more
philanthropic than it's ever been before
why why does that matter i don't know
just came to me it's one of those things
that came to me
a certain point certain time
well i i about
five ten i can't remember the years
where they go but about
seven years ago i looked at my business
and thought
i remember it no it's not longer than
that it was eight years ago
and i my little baby son was born
and um this beautiful little man came
into the world and
on he he was born on the monday
and on the saturday my 18 year old son
was going
out into the world to university
and i mean obviously this you can
imagine the emotions that are going
through my body there's this young
man that's coming to this world and this
young man is going out into this world
and it was just visceral and i i i do
cry when i'm feeling
you know um happy or sad or i listen to
great music
i can it clears me especially if it's
nick cave
and um i kept on crying and just
this movement and i remember sitting
with milo who was going off to do the
very bright land he was going off to do
philosophy and economics
and we were just chatting on the bed i
remember clearing his bedroom and
there's a little cricket back there and
i don't get emotional because i remember
going off to find the cricket bat and i
remember also being
really [ __ ] off because all the sports
shops was closed and they become joby
sports and jiggy sports you know like
no that's not a sports shop i want to go
to a sports shop where someone says i'll
give you the cricket back and
knows about sport and but i found one
in in in sherburne where a friend lived
i found this little and i was looking at
the crooked back and thinking all the
memories you know it's just that lovely
numb
packing his stuff and i'm just looking
at his little hands sitting next to me
on the bed or big hands and
stuff what do you think you'll probably
do because i don't know because
i'm doing economics it goes and i
suppose i'll end up going into finance
in the city and i was like i just
remember this
like this deep and i remember sitting
there and thinking
[Music]
that's not your frequency that's not you
i mean you're you're
go getting your but you've grown up with
me
and you're gonna have to change you
[Music]
to go into that world and then i looked
at the little horatio the baby thinking
this is
this is what we all do we all bloody
have to change
and i thought actually i've done this
i've i've changed i became you know when
i was on the board of harvey nichols the
business woman
when it was mary queen of shops when it
was married whatever on the tv i was
that
what the hell am i doing am i still
doing this
and so i went on that journey then and i
that's when i decided to change the
whole way that i ran the business
and i wrote work like a woman on that
realizing that actually what i had
suppressed
was my deep sensitivity and i called it
my feminine instinct because i do
believe
the power of the feminine has been
suppressed over millennia
there's no two ways about it there's no
two ways about it
we have created a male dominated
alpha energy in the world because we
killed and we through through the church
millions of women who were the sages
who were we've suppressed femininity and
that
power is the power that's going to take
us through
into the next part of the world and i
started looking at this
and i started i never saw myself as a
feminist
because i'd you know look at me i looked
at my life why do i need to be that you
know
and i started to go what are we doing
with our children through work
that we this young man has to suppress
his creativity his sensitivity
to go and be a bastard basically because
they get to the top this was at the time
of you know
money power fame those are the ones your
trumps your philip greens you hear loads
of what you
unite them they're brilliant yes sir
this
and i started to go on that journey then
so that's exactly when it was it was
eight years ago
nearly nine and i wrote the book
created a new culture in my business
opened up started to talk about stuff
that made me feel vulnerable
started to bring in this more
compassionate way of working and
actually connect with what would have
been seen as
soft skills or hr department actually i
believed were going to be the new power
skills
love kindness actually
no because before you know 12 years ago
if someone wasn't working
like oh done out
you know boom on to the next you're not
good enough how do you do that what's
going on in that person's life
i remember discovering one of our great
creatives
suffer with depression and he'd actually
told someone else
and one day he's like that i wouldn't
have looked at that before okay how do
we work with this
so i started on that journey then and
then i realized that you know
over the years that even the planet
that we were killing was all part of
this the way that we
suppressed ourselves in search of more
we've just killed the planet we've
killed our well-being
and i just kept on going on the journey
and then i did a ted talk on it
um and they asked me to do a ted talk
and i thought what am i going to talk
and it just kept them coming up this
theme so i talked on
when i called it we need the kindness
economy we need an economy that isn't
about growth
that isn't about money at any cost that
just doesn't measure
linear how do we create well-being
it's not that i'm anti-capitalism i like
money how do we create a world to that
and i started to go on it
and then covered it bam and it was there
it kept going this is what you're meant
to be doing mary
and i'm looking at how to get back to
make the same money as i did before
and all the while i'm chasing that my
god my business is going there and this
voice is going
just there it's where you meant to be
and then one day i woke up and and i
rang my chief executive i said i think
this is where we need to go and she's
amazing
and i'm also thinking well she's 40
something with two kids and she's you
know
in this business with me it's all right
me going this is amazing can we
but i think we should go this route and
we talked about it and talked about it
just
and the more i talked the more it opened
up and my head of strategy and my answer
proceed we were all like yes
actually we need to be advising business
on being better
better to people and better to the
planet
and that's how it all started and that's
my journey now
that is it am i excited by it no but
do i get up and think that it's deeply
in there with me and i just have to
follow it now
and that's where i'm i hope that
explains it
no you haven't done it it's really
powerful and i think it it perfectly
ties into all the
prior themes of listening to intuition
and um
i think that's super super powerful i i
have two more questions for you one of
them relates to what you've just said
there which is
um in a very practical sense what does
that mean for a business to become more
kind
you talked about people and planet but
in terms of like
the boardroom pay
you know all of it it's actually looking
and going
we we know that simon sinek wrote the
great books on you know
why rather than just it's looking at
what your business
is here for what is your philosophy and
your purpose really understanding that
and connecting it deeply to you on a
human level first of all
and you know you've got a lot of
wokeness going on and
well yeah our purpose is to make the
world better no
you know what is your true
purpose as a business and now once you
start to work on that
and your self and i've done it through
the book
you then create the environment
through your people to how you pay them
through how you inspire them through how
you connect
your customers through your truth of how
you manufacture
how you create how you collaborate
you create a different way of being a
business that's not siloed
it's not individualistic you move from
me to we
so everything that you do you are
thinking
that bit wider than yourself it's like
being a mother
or a parent in any sense undoubtedly
i would always put them first always
not evenly always
so you think about that in your business
doesn't stop me being me
it doesn't stop me developing doesn't
stop me opening up doesn't stop me
growing doesn't
but i am being a responsible connected
kind individual
we need to do this with the world and
the reason i put people
planet profit in their order is the
planet's going to go on without us
we'll [ __ ] it and we'll die quite simply
and it'll regenerate it's done that
as we know i said whatever
but we can make that change happen
we can do it by being more humane by
being kinder
and by creating commerce
that feeds and gives social progress
as well as financial progress
and it's possible it's totally possible
you know that
now obviously some people go it's all
right from us sitting from her money
doing that yeah
i've made money yeah but i'm doing it
and there's people who are doing it who
haven't and those are the ones i take
the hat off to
those are the ones and if i can just put
a bit of volume on it then
i will because i've got a bit of a big
mouth
and i actually you know you know some of
the people i admire the most
one guy in particular called novar he
always talks about how if you want to
start taking on some of these worlds the
world's big problems like the
environment et cetera what you have to
do
is you have to make sure people aren't
worrying about feeding their kids first
and foremost
because i don't begrudge or blame anyone
that can't feed their kids
that that isn't thinking about saving
the environment you know what i mean
because i would be
taking course you know so there's a bit
of sort of fundamental social work that
needs to be done for us to get to a
place where well i mean we can look at
that in terms but it's again what was
value my mother had very little money
but she fed us
and she didn't make us obese by buying
[ __ ] food that was too
cheap yeah same with fashion and people
go oh yeah but that fashion
it's democratic everybody can afford it
you stand out some of those shops
everyone's coming out with three carrier
bags of [ __ ]
that's going to go into landfill or we
don't market the hell out of it
via that and we tell the truth that
buying something that lasts and recycles
and upcycles
and that you share is actually where the
new
sexy is sex is the word you know i it's
really important that is important i
call it status
status symbols we've moved to now we're
into status sentence how do we create a
world where we understand
that being sentient and connecting with
experience
and life and being generous in the world
is more important than symbols big move
massive move and we need to look at the
brands we need to look at power in
business
and that's where i'm starting i wrote
down earlier because you said the word
and it's been something i've been very
curious about the word of meditation
what role is that played in your life
and why did you embark on that
practice because it steals my mind and
your mind is the biggest
tool you have that can just [ __ ] you
over terribly
or it can really ignite you amen
tell me about the upside of meditation
as you've seen it
well i started by doing little podcasts
to listen to someone tell me how to do
it because i was a bit hopeless and
me sitting still ain't great um
and it's just i i do each morning with
it i only do 10 minutes and then i'll
try and do it at the end of the evening
and i still my mind and i just connect
and i feel my energy going to my body
and i clear and any time a little thing
comes in that says
i go thought and then i laugh at it i
don't get annoyed i just go
and i laugh at the me that's the thought
that just tells you all this [ __ ]
and then i just open up
my energy as much as possible and then
during the day where i find myself where
i might be
going out of sync i just have this thing
that just says pause
and i pause and then i relax and i could
be sitting in a meeting like this and
where i might be wanting to talk more
i just stop and let it come back in
and it's just helped me hugely
closing the tabs that's a really good
visual
closing all those tabs down but just
they're not great lastly love
relationships something i think
very you know career driven
professionals like you
um often tend to struggle with for
various variety of reasons
have you struggled with relationships
love holding together relationships
investing in them
i don't think i have i mean i don't
think it looks particularly great that
i've got two
um failed marriages but actually
they there were some brilliant years i
knew they were long
and they created beautiful things so i
don't see them as failure
i genuinely don't see them as failure
it's a part of my life and i
i've changed i i am not the same person
that i was when i met or
and i'm on a very different part of my
journey and that happens
um and i think we can just get
so hung up on that you know i've had
incredible i've had long relationships
now i've never really struggled
with relationships i don't think
no i've had pretty decent long ones
as i was on my own the last which has
been the first time in in
ages that was really unique for me you
know
when was this just recently you know i
split up with my
wife melanie back in three years ago
and i was you know three years on my own
still single now
no but i'm not going to tell you who is
that'll be a nice headline
[Music]
who are you with i i i sound fair to
them you know because it's just
no no one in the public eye and order
would they want we want to be thrown
into it but
but you found that's that's super yes
dare i say exciting
that's some very nice joy but
but but came in a i think i manifested
it as well
really yeah i just thought oh god now
i'm ready for something and i i
genuinely feel i sort of
opened up my we spend so much time
feeding energies that just
are not worth it that you just have to
keep pushing up
in that three years what did you what
was what did you tell yourself
because a lot of people when they when
the garage is empty they just want to
fill it with anything
do you know what i mean because that
makes them feel they feel complete or
you know
when there's someone there they feel
like they need someone just to fill the
garage but
what did you do for those three years to
patience i guess or you know you talked
about manifesting well probably one of
the most toughest three years of my life
at least three years i
i grieved first of all the loss of your
marriage yeah
you grieve and i think you have to
grieve
and um
[Music]
covert hit not easy i had to gosh on
your own
and or yeah you're on yeah yeah and you
have your kids
and you're resettling where you live so
you everything changed
everything so my business changed
my marriage ended where i lived changed
so it was a huge amount of change and
actually the last thing
i was able to do was bring anyone into
that i had to be
with me um
[Music]
yeah and it was it was very very painful
very painful and
a lot and i i think it's only in the
last
six to ten months i've come through
amazing well listen mary you've um been
just the best guest ever so hilarious
and intelligent and honest
which is amazing i need to be more
hilarious i was just thinking you're
thinking of [ __ ] i need to be more funny
am i funny you are funny yeah
oh that's that's the only time you're
funny through being honest no this is
the thing you're just honest and a lot
of people
they skirt around what they they truly
think because they're trying to find the
correct
politically correct words or phrases and
you don't seem to give a [ __ ] which i
think makes for great listening
you you're already there well yeah i i
am
yeah but maybe you're more descriptive
so it's even more hilarious
but i you know yeah just thank you so
much my pleasure and thank you for
rescheduling me
another bit of a nightmare you were
definitely worth it
i really appreciate it love and luck for
all you do thank you please shine your
light in the world that's needed i mean
it i'll do my very best
[Music]
oh
[Music]
you